the samsung galaxy s3 has been in-house
for a little bit now and my experience
has been very positive so far actually
this is a device that samsung has made a
big deal out of and it's just about the
most highly anticipated android handset
of the entire year 2012 so without any
further ado here are my brief first
impressions now i say brief first
impressions because i'm actually going
to new york today june 19th to attend
the launch event for the us version of
this phone so let me know what you guys
want to see about the phone you know
battery life long term durability you
know all kinds of stuff let me know in
the comment section below the like
button on this video and i will go ahead
and do my best to show you all these
things but we can start on the outside
of this phone and right off the bat it
kind of reminds me of the curves of the
magic mouse i might be the only one who
thinks that but it definitely has that
reminder in my head every time i look at
it it's just in the same footprint as
the galaxy nexus actually even though it
has a larger 4.8 inch display and it's a
little bit thinner and a little bit
lighter as well at the bottom this is
one of the unique things about this
there's a capacitive menu button and a
back button that are invisible unless
you're using the phone and there's a
physical home button in the middle i
actually really like this layout
especially with the menu button there it
just looks really clean i like it and
you can control how long these buttons
stay lit and when they turn are visible
in the settings and when they're off
they're actually invisible like you
can't tell that they're there if you
didn't know it just looks so clean very
very classy i like it and of course the
main star of the show here is
performance the galaxy s3 is literally
one of the best spec lineups of any
smartphone to date and it shows now
there is touchwiz on top and there is
plenty of samsung in your face and you
can tell right from the unlock screen
but i can show you some ways to get out
of that in the full review but overall
i've been very happy with the general
performance of the galaxy s3 touch
response especially is excellent it's
probably the best of any android device
next to the galaxy nexus and this is
something samsung does really well your
finger glides across the glass and it
absolutely keeps up with everything
which is awesome now there will be some
very heavy you know heavy gaming and
some really crazy stuff done in the full
review just so you guys know but just
just know that this is absolutely a
monster on paper and this absolutely
takes over benchmarks like no other
phone i have ever seen it just destroys
some benchmarks and also this isn't a
nexus device so there's going to be some
pre-installed samsung stuff here and
there for example samsung replaces the
google calendar app with something
called s planner stuff like that and it
bothered me at first as an android sort
of purist but i'll accept the added
features i kind of like them from
samsung they're actually kind of nice so
overall this is clearly an exciting
device and i'm looking forward to
testing every single aspect of its
hardware and software so hopefully your
help and your comments we can cover
everything either way thank you for
watching subscribe if you haven't
already to watch the full review when
that comes out soon and i will talk to
you guys later peace
[Music]
you